what is your uh what Native uh tribe are
you I was Calientes hot water Indians in
Palm Springs [ __ ] yeah I've seen that
[ __ ] before yeah I feel like while I'm
while I'm over there I see that like on
signs yeah yeah is that like who has the
casinos out there there are casinos it's
a reservation it's just a whole little
it's a whole different world bro it's
crazy it's like almost going back in
time to like 18 17 16 like all those old
years centuries ago so in AZ we have a I
grew up around a lot of natives uh like
the navajos and there's tons of tribes
in Arizona
um and um their casinos you can't drink
or Gamble
in the casino that your own tribe owns
is it like a Pechanga like what's the
casino called there's a bunch there's
like Casino Arizona yes Talking Stick
there's a bunch but like yeah there's
like a rule that like you can't drink or
gamble yeah if you're a native at the
casino because it's like they look like
it's customary well it's like bad for
the for their people sure sure
um but between different native tribes
and like Native American Indians there's
always just different you know there's
different things that you can and can't
do I feel like there's like Cherokee
navajos and then you have the patches
there's different morals and principles
that differ all of them just possess but
as far as patches are just the ganks
they're like the [ __ ]
yeah they're like you know they're
they're like the big you them [ __ ]
will hop out bam big trucks they're all
smoke shout out to the Apaches yeah
[ __ ] okay so you're like like what is
your racial you're a racially ambiguous
I'm everywhere bro if you've seen me
you're like this [ __ ] is just [ __ ]
just everything yeah so what is
everything it's crazy that's you know I
love you you're 23andMe I love to keep
the CR I love to create the mysticism I
love that show you're Mexican as well
yeah I'm Mexican too Mexican Mexican
black Native American wow and I think I
got you know do you know when you do the
little ancestry.com [ __ ] got some
Nigerian some Spaniard in them but you
know so you did [ __ ] can't really
count that yeah I did that yeah I just
ordered some for Black Friday I ordered
the test kit you did yeah you're gonna
find out you black [ __ ] seventy percent
I'm gonna find he's just albino I'm ex
I'm as white as I thought I was
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] you